where's Al that's the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
now there's only one thing worse than Al
Sharpton claiming to care about black
people it's Al Sharpton in one of his
Protege pretending to care about black
people well each of them celebrate one
another
you got convictions was the first time
we had convictions of a police officer
like that in all the years that I've
been involved sure and this was
Monumental you've set the template on
how to do these kind of cases all of us
remember how you talked about get off
our neck you'll remember that that was
such an important moment and you were a
voice for the people because of the the
precedent you laid down and many others
lay down wait wait Al Sharpton did he
say a voice for the people
especially if it's police involved like
of course the tragic case of George
Floyd
you cared about the family the human
price that uh people pay to lose a loved
one well you know people who lose their
loved ones to police brutality are Crime
Victims they are Crime Victims and any
prosecutor worth his or her salt is
going to make this victims Center and so
this is something I've felt compelled to
do
neither Keith Ellison the AG of
Minnesota nor Al Sharpton are anything
but racial opportunists so if a crime
involving a black person can offer you
know a PR or political benefit or in the
case of someone like Sharpton or
Attorney Benjamin Crump a financial
payday they might get prominently
involved otherwise don't hold your
breath
and on the nuts and bolts issues that
actually plagued the black community
especially in urban areas the racial
industrial complex is either nowhere to
be found or actively working against the
black community
how much time has Al Sharpton for
instance devoted to the persistent
problem of black gang violence in
Minneapolis my child can't play in the
yard
I I hear four gunshots a night there's
so much drug trafficking there is so
much gang violence I've never seen it
this bad I think and not anybody has
seen it this bad
gang violence in Minneapolis is so bad
that the feds got involved doj issued a
major indictment of 45 gang members a
few weeks ago didn't get much coverage
alleging members of The Gangs called the
highs and the Bloods engaged in a brutal
and unrelenting trail of violence over
the course of years including Revenge
killings and alleged trafficking in
Fentanyl and methamphetamine now our own
mitobin
um on our own Mike Tobin to an active
member of the Gangster Disciples
recently about violence in the city
these gangs are Reckless
real Reckless it's not organized no more
it used to be structure in there no
women no kids now it's just a free fall
who knows how many black residents of
Minneapolis gangs have you know they've
killed over the years by either drugs or
murder
but where's Reverend now
why isn't he or one of his acolytes
they're mentoring youth to keep them out
of the gangs
because there's no Fame in it and
there's certainly no money in it
and not a peep from Sharpton about this
Savage attack six teens on bicycles
savagely beat what appeared to be a
white man in LA
and this was just a few days ago the
video was disturbing
[Music]
[Applause]
we're the parents we're the fathers who
raise these kids and where's Al Sharpton
or because the victim looks like was
white does this not count as Injustice
and the good Reverend's eyes
and the Reason by the way the brave
social justice Warriors don't care to
address the recurrent lack on Asian
attacks in our cities well in Long Beach
California last week a 53-year-old
victim said her attacker yelled racial
slurs at her before punching her face I
thought I was going to die she told the
local reporter too scared to even share
her name the attackers are still on the
loose
again this is wanton violence for no
reason
broken families a criminal justice
system that's overloaded and that too
often treats criminals like victims and
victims like criminals
so does Al Sharpton and his Pals believe
that racism is the reason that teens as
young as 13 in Maryland are stealing
cars
and I looked and I looked and I found no
sign of Al Sharpton speaking out last
week after this shocking story out of
Oxen Hill Maryland came out where a 14
year old girl orchestrated and attempted
murder on a school bus
now these stories speak to deeper
challenges in the communities that
Sharpton and Crump claim to care so much
about
broken homes deadbeat dads and marijuana
use at a young age
if Al Sharpton spent as much time
advocating for fathers as he does
against so-called systemic bias and
policing he would really have made a
huge impact
now ditto for views on the issues that
hurt minority families most open borders
it's a nightmare for inner city America
it sucks up Social Services crowd
schools but Al Sharpton he wants to let
in more illegals not fewer I talked to
the uh Secretary of Homeland Security uh
Maracas I said that to him that they
must stop
immediately the deportations
from 2018 Ellison thinks the
corporations certain people who get
certain rights can go back and forth
across the border seeking out the lowest
wages but people regular people cannot
go back and forth across the border
seeking out the highest wages
well the cartels can now how's it
working out for us now of course all an
open border does other than fill our
cities with drugs is drive down wages
for entry-level workers in the United
States which disproportionately hurts
young and minority workers
but the race Hustlers don't care about
this in fact to stay in lockstep with
the Democrats they support policies that
would leave law-abiding
African-Americans defenseless I think
that the real issue is what they're
fighting about which is still alive with
two shootings just yesterday where are
we going to arrive and when are we going
to arrive at dealing with gun control
that's the real issue
now the real issue here is the Democrats
grandstand on race and don't do a darn
thing to offer real solutions
where were these self-appointed civil
rights icons when Tony fauci and Randy
Weingarten were pushing for school
lockdowns during covid we know remote
learning hurt minorities the worst they
lost education mental illness depression
it was also easy to predict as we did
here on the angle but not the not so
Reverend Reverend he just told the party
line
and pot legalization it's been a
nightmare for the states where it's been
tried and especially disastrous for our
Young Black and Hispanic youth fueling
more cartel violence and homelessness
but Sharpton he's all for it the
question of of medical marijuana and the
question of decriminalization it is a
natural fit it should be a civil right
for people to maintain and enhance their
health blacks cannot be the ones that go
to jail and others go to the bank
you see the pattern here the fact is Al
Sharpton and his ilk have been Crusaders
for the left on pretty much every social
and economic policy that has deeply
wounded the black community and they
simultaneously inflame racial tensions
with their fake charges of intrinsic
racism across American Life all for
their own political and economic benefit
it is a sick and it is a twisted game
they're playing and I can't help but
hope that more black voters see through
the charade before any more damage is
done and any more lives are lost
next time you see a horrific crime and
ask where's Al
you might look in the MSNBC Green Room
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else